bonjour jean claude beaujour merci de
répondre à nos questions dans quel état
d'esprit sont les américains avec cette
menace de shut down imminente
les américains je pense à ceux qui au
quotidien
vive la crise tremble parce que si le
président des états unis ne signe pas
aussi met son veto ce sont des centaines
de milliers de chèques qu'ils ne
partiront pas alors même que ces mêmes
américains ses concitoyens ont besoin de
cette somme au moins 600 euros peut-être
plus il faut savoir que en moyenne ce
qui vise certains nombre d'américains
c'est l'impossibilité de faire face à
leurs premiers besoins
c'est le risque également d'être exclus
de leurs logements au 31 12 31 janvier
le régime protecteur qui visait à
empêcher ou à limiter le risque
d'expulsion les sera soulevée dans qui
lie à toute une série de dispositifs
dans cette dans ce projet de loi dans
cette loi que n'a pas ratifié n'a pas
encore ratifié signé le président qui
pourrait toucher des amériques et moyens
parce que ce programme visait à protéger
à renforcer la protection sur les ce
qu'on appelle chez nous les années
pendant les restaurateurs les business
soutenu par les gérer parmi les
minorités bref c'est l'américain de base
qui est considérablement visé en outre
et vous l'avez très bien dit dans dans
votre reportage le risque de chutes
d'arbres de l'administration des
milliers des centaines de milliers de
fonctionnaires ne serait pas payée
c'est une situation qui est inacceptable
alors même que nous venons de vivre
plusieurs noir de crise sanitaire et que
le chômage est quand même très important
aux états unis et quelle chance pour que
donald trump signe le texte
on sait qu'il ya une passe d'armes entre
républicains et démocrates alors le
président qui est vous savez dans sa
résidence de floride pour pour les
vacances d'hiver a dit qu'il attendait
un nouveau projet nul doute qu'il fera
durer le suspense mais il n'a pas non
plus un thé
je pense là sur le plan politique
puisque votre question c'est est quelle
chance de signature il n'a pas non plus
intérêt à laisser pourrir la situation
parce que n'oublions pas donald trump ne
sera pas un président à la retraite père
de la nation il l'entend certainement
joue un rôle politique aux etats-unis
pour la suite quel que soit ce que l'on
peut penser par ailleurs mais je pense
que dans sa tête il veut continuer à
jouer un rôle et il n'a pas donc intérêt
à se mettre lui une grande majorité
d'américains ados notamment dans ses
électeurs parce que chez les acteurs de
donald trump
il y a des gens qui souffrent
terriblement de la crise comme je vous
donne l exemple des restaurateurs comme
je vous donne un exemple d'indépendants
dans toute l'amérique il y à des
américains qui souffrent et dorsaz il
faut il est élevé aussi sur le fil du
rasoir
ultime pied de nez de donald trump avant
de quitter la maison blanche
on sait que donald trump va céder son
fauteuil à joe biden
20 janvier prochain absolument il ne
faut pas oublier donc le 6 le 6 janvier
en principe les les membres du congrès
vont se réunir pour pouvoir confirmer la
décision des grands électeurs donc nous
ment joe byden président des états unis
de 20 janvier
la passation de pouvoir aura lieu aux
alentours dans un raid midi heure de
washington
et donc on sait bien que dans cette
histoire à la fois
donald trump considère qu'il n'a pas été
soutenu pendant la campagne n'a pas été
suffisamment soutenu pendant la campagne
par ses amis républicains
mais il a aussi très rapidement compris
que dans la bataille judiciaire qu'ils
viennent de lancer qu'il a lancé tout au
long de ces quelques semaines qui ont
suivi le 3 novembre
souvenez vous on s'attendait à ce que
des décisions soient plus ou moins en sa
faveur décisions judiciaires l'entente
alors qu'il a nommé énormément c'est par
le parquet de la cour suprême
mais là nous met énormément de juges
alors que les tpe aux responsabilités
il a eu en quelque sorte qu'à bouffer de
la part de la cour suprême
eh bien il a été il considère qu'il est
lâché par ses amis républicains et il
entend le leur rappeler d'ailleurs vous
voyez qu'il dit je m'en souviendrai un
mot pour revenir sur ce shakedown
quelles seraient les conséquences
on sait qu'il ya la crise sanitaire qui
a fortement impacté les américains outre
atlantique
alors pour ceux qui saluent quant au
canton c'est jaune aaa washington
washington par exemple je me rends
compte que beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
washington y un sont liés à l'activité
gouvernementale donc dans les
administrations et lorsqu'il y à un choc
dame l'hélice les fonctionnaires ne sont
pas autorisés à travailler pour certains
d'entre eux en tout cas la plupart ne
sont pas payés sont en attente
bref ça crée une situation économique
dévastatrice dysfonctionnement du
service public bien sûr sur le plan
strict de la continuité du service
public vu à l'européenne mais aussi
dysfonctionnement social
donc c'est vrai que ça peut provoquer
certains malins soit une certaine
explosion sociale
là encore alors même que nous vivons
c'est la crise dans la crise nous vivons
la crise sanitaire depuis un certain
nombre de mois aux etats unis
merci jean claude beaujour d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat et vice président de
france amérique
merci à